[Music]
in this stage at CPAC on Friday y'all
happy to see the president he's coming
to see you he has a lot of
accomplishments to talk about and now of
course these are all things that the
destroy Trump media never reports on
because it doesn't fit their narrative
they are singularly focused on one thing
and it's not the truth it's not evidence
it's not facts it's about how to tear
down this president by any means
necessary now that's why they'll never
tell you that under the President Trump
this is one year unemployment in America
17-year low african-american Hispanic
unemployment have also reached record
lows now under one year president Trump
thank you
jobless claims are at a 45 year low and
since the election 2.5 million new jobs
have been created and there are two
million fewer Americans on food stamps
in the country we have consumer
confidence near a 17-year high business
confidence has now reached levels not
seen since President Reagan and all of
that is before the president's historic
tax cuts have even started to kick in 90
percent of Americans are expected to see
bigger paychecks three million more
Americans have received bonuses oh and
by the way those bonuses that the
Democrats like Nancy Pelosi they're
calling thousands of dollars in bonuses
crumbs
it's a crumb if you're a hundred million
dollar net wealth person like Nancy
Pelosi those crumbs I don't think that's
a chrome new all right also on the
economy President Trump is reversing
what was a precipitous decline that we
witnessed under eight disastrous years
of failed Obama policies President Trump
is cutting regulation at a historic rate
we're eliminating 16 for every new
regulation enacted look what it's done
for the energy sector alone Isis has
been crushed because he has allowed the
military to do their job we are now
rebuilding the military
thank you and the president's demanding
that the border border wall be built in
any immigration legislation now if a
Democrat had accomplished half of what
President Trump has at this point in
their presidency the liberal media would
be trying to put this individual on
Mount Rushmore they want Obama on Mount
Rushmore in spite of his failure but we
also have those in the media in this
country that's not how they operate now
for over a year
the news media colluding with of course
liberals in this country and basically
advancing their agenda they have been
hyperventilating over what we have
exposed so far as a hoax a conspiracy a
fabrication and that is they created
about Donald Trump and Trump Russia
collusion even though the media knows
there's no evidence to prove any of this
is true after nearly 18 months there is
zero evidence but yet look at the
disgraceful coverage you get every
single night from your so-called
mainstream media a dizzying 24 hours and
the Russian investigation no longer just
inching toward the president this
morning it is more like careening I
think this is a potentially more
dangerous situation than Watergate and
we're at a very dangerous moment and
that's because we are looking at the
possibility that the President of the
United States and those around him
during an election campaign colluded
with a hostile foreign power to
undermine the basis of our democracy
Donald Trump is afraid a political
hurricane is out there at sea for him
we'll call it hurricane vladimer if you
will the whole Russian thing this is
evidence of willingness to commit
collusion
there's outright treason I mean there is
no question that what he is doing is
giving aid and comfort to the enemy Tom
Friedman said the election hacking is at
the caliber of a Pearl Harbor or a 9/11
you agree with that I completely agree
with that Donald Trump now sits at the
threshold of impeachment
let me get through react it just shows
you the people in the media are nothing
but liars and frauds and by the way
they're really just an extension of the
Democratic Party by the way speaking of
Liberal Democrats they've been in
lockstep with the media and you'll
notice they all say the same thing they
parrot each other their fake phony
talking points and their little bubble
so you've had Democrats the media over a
year
pushing a made-up false narrative about
so-called collusion but now it's all
beginning to start boomeranging back as
I predicted at the beginning of this
year everything the media has accused
Donald Trump of and his campaign of
doing with Russia is exactly what
Hillary Clinton and the DNC and fusion
GPS and Christopher Steele are all
guilty of and people should go to jail
and likely will go to jail over all of
this and that is the real Russia
collusion story and unlike the media's
fake news narrative we have real
concrete incontrovertible evidence of
real crimes and real wrongdoing let's
look at the phony dossier for example
Hillary Clinton the DNC they paid over
12 plus million dollars for the former
British spy oh I thought foreigners
weren't supposed to influence our
elections anyway to create a completely
unverified dossier that used Russian
government lies and sources and steal
who hates Donald Trump didn't want them
to win the election then briefs the
media outlets let's see like the New
York Times The Washington Post Yahoo
News The New Yorker fake News the whole
network CNN and they try to influence
the election and manipulate the American
voters and Fuzion GPS their co-founder
Glenn Simpson he testified that the
Clinton campaign in the DNC were aware
of all of this media outreach now that
sounds an awful lot like that they were
using a phony Russian narrative phony
Russian information that they bought and
paid for to influence the American
people and to win the election that way
and then on top of that you got steel
meeting with the FBI still giving them
all of this Russian sourced information
we now know from two GOP memos that that
dossier was used to lie to a FISA Court
judge all in an effort to get a warrant
to spy on a trump campaign associate and
the campaign that of course being Carter
page and the memos also are exposing how
former FBI director Andrew McCabe he
testified without the dossier the
application for that warrant would never
have even been applied for certainly not
approved and we know from the Grassley
Graham memo that the bulk of that
application consisted of Hillary
Clinton's bought and paid for dossier
now remember this is the dossier that
James Comey testified under oath was
salacious and unverified the FBI
infusion GPS they never bothered even
begin to corroborate this and then you
had called me remember back in January
at 2017 briefing the president-elect
before he's inaugurated about how the
dossier existed and he said it was
unverified and salacious now that was
only months before when he in 2060 and
in October well he was that dossier
that's unverified was good enough to use
as a justification to spy on Carter page
this is what we call the deep state
inaction this is unelected Obama
holdover bureaucrats they thought they
knew better than you the American people
about who should be the next president
and make no mistake about this the deep
state tried to stop Donald Trump from
ever becoming president and now they're
doing everything they possibly can do to
damage and destroy his presidency and at
one point remember at the beginning of
his administration over a hundred and
twenty-five leaks and 126 days now
here's the thing about all of this the
corrupt officials are all now being
exposed they never thought this would
happen
everything is boomeranging back on them
and as we like to say on my Twitter
account tick-tock what we have been
reporting on for the past year is only a
small sample of what is coming we expect
the inspector general's report to have a
lot of new information and that will be
coming either by the end of this month
or early next month